the israeli army says it has struck
hamas targets in the gaza strip
early on wednesday the bombings are an
apparent retaliation
for rockets fired from the hamas
controlled territory the previous
evening
now the rockets were launched as israel
the united arab emirates and bahrain
signed accords in washington to
normalize diplomatic relations u.s
president donald trump hosting
that white house ceremony placing
himself in the role of international
peacemaker
peacemaker rather ahead of elections in
november
we're here this afternoon to change the
course of history
after decades of division and conflict
we mark the dawn of a
new middle east thanks to the great
courage of the leaders of these three
countries we take a major stride toward
a future in which people of all faiths
and backgrounds live together in peace
and prosperity
in israel's entire history there have
previously been only two such agreements
now we have achieved two
in a single month and there are more to
follow
thank you very much the decision by the
united arab emirates and bahrain to
normalize ties with israel
breaks with decades of consensus within
the arab world
a peace deal with the palestinians has
long been upheld as a prerequisite for
establishing relations with israel
trump and netanyahu are hopeful though
that other arab nations will
follow suit creating a major shift in
ties in the region
and the blessings of the peace we make
today
will be enormous
first because this peace will eventually
expand
to include other arab states
and ultimately it can end the arab
israeli conflict once and for all
but the agreements do not address the
core conflict between israel
and the palestinians bahrain's foreign
minister
also made it clear that it was too early
to celebrate
a just comprehensive and enduring
two-state solution to the
palestinian-israeli conflict
will be the foundation the bedrock of
such peace
in the palestinian territories the new
agreements have been
met with anger
warning sirens sounded as several
rockets fired from the gaza strip
hit israeli territory
earlier hundreds rallied in the occupied
west bank
and the gaza strip
this agreement today is an agreement
that betrays the palestinian cause
and stabs the palestinian people and
this
emirati bahrainian agreement is a
withdrawal from the arab initiative
and the arab unison we say no to
normalization
and this normalization is a betrayal a
betrayal to the palestinian corps
and pan-arabism of course the
palestinian people denounce this
agreement
the palestinian leadership has made it
clear that only israel's withdrawal from
the occupied territories can bring peace
but as israel and gaza again exchange
fire
that seems as far away a goal as ever
all right i want to bring in now rabbi
mark schneier he was at the signing
ceremony at the white house rabbi
schneier is known as the rabbi to the
muslim world
he's a special adviser to king hamad bin
isa al-khalifa of bahrain
rabbi shania he joins me on the phone
tonight welcome back to the day rabbi
what does today's what does today's
signing ceremony
what does it change in the middle east
well i think it's an extraordinary
transformation
because unlike half empire peace
agreement
and this is all about opportunity
particularly in the realm
of economics this partnership how many
golf
leaders have expressed to me
these past few years that with our
resources and wealth and israel's brain
trust and technology
that together we could develop the most
powerful economic
region in the world so i believe that
economics you know is a
very strong engine that's driving this
process
cover 19. there needs to be a regional
response
uh the controversy over israel possibly
annexing the west bank
and the emiratis and bahrainians very
much rescued a two-state solution here
and of course you have the
existentialist challenge and
threat the ongoing threat coming from
iran and the satellites
that i do believe the gulf states are
looking to israel to
step in and to become its uh defender
and protector i
so there are a host of reasons here
when you and i spoke last month you said
that these agreements are a victory for
the palestinians and that
they mean that there will be discussions
about a two-state
solution there were no palestinian
representatives at the white house
today well it's no different than
the way the palestinians boycotted the
conference in bahrain last year
at the peace 2 prosperity conference
there are those of us including myself
who believe that the road to the israeli
palestinian reconciliation must go
through
economics and the gulf states today
acknowledge
they have skin in the game they're going
to have to bring a sense of economic
opportunities empowerment
and hope to the palestinian people that
can really be the engine that can bring
about this kind of reconciliation
israel with this agreement has
normalized ties with two arab countries
that do not want to answer
claims about human rights violations
within their own borders
let me ask you as a man of faith what
did the jewish state
sacrifice in order to win or to reach
new states of normal relations with the
uae and bahrain
i don't think the state of israel
sacrificed anything yeah i've been in
the region now for more than 12 years
and i have seen
some dramatic dramatic improvements
uh on the human rights front in terms of
um
how the different rulers are conducting
themselves in terms of their own
populations
so i think it's just uh you know a
journey
and that's going to continue and grow
and develop to the promised land of a
genuine authentic democracy in that
region
well as that development takes place i'm
sure we will be talking with you again
we hope so rabbi
mark schneier joining us tonight from
washington d.c rabbi thank you
my pleasure thank you
israeli relations with bahrain and the
uae are
already good some observers say today's
agreement is a de facto confirmation of
what has been happening for years
is there more to the deal in the eyes of
israelis
our jerusalem correspondent tanya kramer
takes a look
in this report the first commercial
flight from tel aviv to abu dhabi a long
isolation period for
israel and the region has ended until
now it only has signed
peace treaties with egypt and jordan in
august israel normalized ties with the
united arab emirates
bahrain followed a month later brokered
by the u.s
it signals a change of alliances in the
region
for us it creates a much stronger
sunni-israeli alliance against iran
against the shiite taxes which is very
important
if we look at american elections in
november when we have a democratic
candidate
that declares that they want to go back
to the previous
nuclear deal with iran such an alliance
of israeli and sunni nations
in the middle east is extremely
important what this doesn't solve is
israel's conflict with the palestinians
the uae has insisted that israel
suspends its plans to annex
parts of the occupied west bank at least
temporarily
but the deal breaks with the public
position of arab countries to refrain
from normalizing relations with israel
until it ends its occupation over
millions of palestinians
in tel aviv the mood among israelis is
mixed as people prepare for a nationwide
lockdown
it's excellent i opened a school for
arabic i did it to promote peace and now
i think it is even more important
it's only for political interest for
bibi for trump and also the uae because
of
arms and for good relations with the us
they don't really care about us
i think it's more needed to deal with
many problems we have here that have to
do with the lockdown corona
and more political problems the country
is very unstable
and there's a lot to take care of before
dealing with external issues
the agreements are seen as a huge
achievement for prime minister benimi
netanyahu
but as he faces a corruption trial and
is under fire for his poor handling of
the pandemic
they're also a rare piece of good news
all right well for a different
perspective the view from europe i'd
like to pull in christiane
hanold he's the senior middle east
expert at germany's berylsman
foundation mr honolulu it's good to have
you on the day
at the white house today it was all
about
israel the uae bahrain
and the united states as the broker
noticeably
absent were the palestinians what about
the europeans
the europeans are not present in this
deal-making policy of trump is having
the middle east
trump has a totally different strategic
approach to change
new trends in the middle east it's
without multilateral institutions like
the eu
it it ignores u.n resolutions or
international agreements or even the
quartet which is the
mediation mechanism towards the
israeli-palestinian
the conflict with a footnote brand the
hungarian foreign minister was present
that was the footnote but they knew not
okay that was the european there
in the room what do you make of claims
that these
deals um motivated by fears of iran
in that the u.s has torpedoed the iran
nuclear deal which the eu has tried to
save
so today's agreement it almost comes at
the expense
of europe
um look germany germany has the eu
presidency and in germany there are
three issues
vis-a-vis this new trends of the middle
east on the table the one is
uh the german government is relieved uh
that the hold of annexation of
palestinian territories by the israeli
government has been achieved
they hope that with the uae year special
that there will be a drive towards
israeli-palestinian understanding
there is a window of opportunity what is
told here in berlin
on the other hand the big concern in
europe is
that in the forthcoming running election
campaign in the us
that the american iranian confrontation
could lead to further escalation uh
already next
next monday there is again a fight on
the united secure united nations
security council on the iranian issue
so that is still an issue of concern is
it likely that other countries are going
to follow
what we've seen today in saudi arabia
saying tonight that it is sticking by
the the plan for the arab world that
first there has to be
a resolution to the palestinian-israeli
problem
before any other deals can be made
there is a paradigm shift since the arab
uh
peace initiative from 2002 which said
all 22 arab
states do wait for palestinian state
before
normalizing with israel this is now
changing
uh more arab countries would like to go
into
more strong relations with the us and
with israel
and this is mainly driven by strong
economic and technological
uh um wishes you know the especially the
countries
in the gulf uh want to
get more innovation the
very late arab country they see their
economic links much more with the us and
with israel
in order to get their country forward uh
the
you know the states in in the gulf
region they will have
they can depend less on oil export in
the future they need to
look for new business and employment
opportunities
and and and this has these new political
trends that
is with more cooperation with innovative
countries like israel
and the us let me ask you about today's
developments
maybe through the eyes of the german
chancellor angela merkel um
she has said that israel's security is a
central tenet of german policy
now when you hear that i would assume
that berlin must be
pleased by the developments today
because these developments
are helping to stabilize israel and its
security
uh germany and and europe have in all
recent years
always trying to push more cooperation
between israel and its arab neighbors
and uh and trying to get the palestinian
issue
solved um this always goes together
and uh and there and we also share the
same concerns
uh about the iranian threat towards uh
towards israel and arab countries in the
region
the approach is different the american
approach vis-a-vis
the iranian threat is maximum pressure
and trump said you know when we are when
i am re-elected
iran will come and make a deal with me
in 30 days the europeans and others at
the united nations security council
think
uh it has to go uh within with an
agreement and controlled by uh
by the iao in vienna in order to get
iran uh back into um
back into less escalation in the region
i've got about half a minute here i want
to ask you what happens next year when
the german chancellor
steps down when when angela merkel is no
longer
in charge what happens to europe or
germany and europe's of support for
israel any change
no there is no change in the you know
all governments
led by social democrats or by greens or
by
uh or or by conservative parties there
is a broad understanding
uh uh about the security of israel um
and peace and development in the middle
east um
i i even observe that there will be more
engagement also driven by germany and
france
uh to foster modernization development
in the mediterranean and in the southern
neighborhood
and took and and to really to get a
conflict in the region
solved all right christian honored with
germany's bettlesmen
foundation mr hunt we appreciate your
time and your insights tonight thank you
it's a pleasure to meet you brandon
you